puis radio canada a appris que la
montreal maine et atlantique n'était pas
ses premiers manquements sur la manière
d'immobiliser ses trains nos collègues
d' enquêtes ont obtenu une liste des
infractions commises par la compagnie
ferroviaire dans les années précédant la
catastrophe
sylvie fournier si la question au coeur
de lanquais combien de frein à main et
ont été appliquées sur le convoi de m et
mme en avant qu'ils ne partent à la
dérive causant la dévastation au centre
ville de lac-mégantic la règle 112 exige
un nombre de freins à main suffisant et
aux tests de traction pour s'assurer que
le train ne bouge pas or cette règle est
même à la enfreinte à répétition enquête
a obtenu au moins huit avertissements
émis par transports canada entre 2004 et
2012 y compris à nantes
là où le convoi de nma a amorcé sa
descente mortel au lendemain de la
tragédie et bercail
le patron de mma a congédié son
conducteur laissant entendre qu'il est
elle responsable
mais les manquements répétés à la règle
112 tmt plutôt d'une culture de sécurité
déficiente au sein de mma et du laxisme
de transports canada selon jacques der
leyen consultant ferroviaire il ya des
avertissements il ya des avis il y a
des reformations du personnel qui sont
prévues mais il n'y a pas à proprement
parler de sanctions même sens que
transports canada a failli à sa mission
aux communes la ministre des transports
richard a dû défendre son ministère et
même en seraient punis sévèrement at
elle martelé
s'il s'avère qu'elle a enfreint les
règles dans un mot toutefois pour
expliquer l'absence de sanction de la
part de transports canada devant ces
infractions répétées transports canada
s'est montré plus sévère envers mm an
après la tragédie en émettant une et vie
assortie d'un ordre cinq locomotives et
98 vague ans avait été laissé sans
surveillance
et encore une fois sans le nombre
suffisant de frein à main sur une partie
de la voie principale
et c'était à 5 km de lac-mégantic ici
sylvie fournier radio canada montréal